carolyn invested one thousand dollars in
an account getting three percent annual
interest compounded monthly
compounded monthly how long will it take
to the nearest whole year for that money
to grow to fifteen hundred dollars so
the amount that she started with we'll
call that p p for principal she's
starting with one thousand dollars and
when you say three percent annual
interest compounded monthly what they're
really saying is that you get one
twelfth of this 3 percent every month so
the interest rate
the interest rate in question if we view
it on a per month basis which is
actually the relevant time period
because they're saying it's compounded
monthly the interest rate is going to be
3
divided by 12
per month
per month which is the same thing as
0.25
percent
per
per month so if we ask ourselves how
much will she have after one month well
she started with a thousand dollars she
started with a thousand dollars and
she's going to add
0.25 percent
times a thousand dollars this is
actually at this is just after one month
or if you factor the thousand out she's
going to have a thousand
times one plus
0.25
percent this is after one month after
two months you would then grow this
amount by one plus
zero point two five percent so then
after two months you would multiply that
times one plus zero point two five
percent after three months you'd have to
multiply this whole thing again by this
amount by one plus so times one plus
zero point two five percent
so this is after three months so this is
three months four months we'd multiply
it again so after n months so after n
month she would have her original
principle one thousand dollars times
one plus zero point two five percent and
i'm not adding it on purpose just so
that you can kind of see what we're
doing so this is how much you would have
after n after n months but we want to
figure out how many months will it take
her to get to fifteen hundred dollars so
we wanna say well what does n have to be
equal to for this this amount to be
equal to fifteen hundred
for this to be fifteen hundred dollars
or another way to think about it this is
saying let me just rewrite it let me
actually just add this we have one
thousand
times
one point let's see
0.25 percent
0.25 percent is the same thing as
0.00 we're going to have to move the
decimal two spaces to the left 0 0
to 5. so this is going to be 1.0025
to the n is equal to 1500
dollars now we can divide both sides by
a thousand and you get 1.0025
to the n is equal to
1500 over 1000 which is just equal to
1.5 i just divided both that and that by
a thousand and then to solve for n to
solve for n we can take the logarithm of
both sides and i'll just take log base
10 because that's useful we have that on
our calculator so i'll just write log
this is really log base 10 i'm going to
take the log of both sides and then log
of 1.0025 to the n that's the same exact
thing using our logarithm properties we
can take that n and bring it out front
that's the exact same thing as n log of
1.0025
and then to solve for n we can just
divide both sides by log of 1.0025
so let's we'll divide both sides by log
of 1.0025
log of 1.002
this cancels out we're left with on the
left hand side just an n n is equal to
log of 1.5 divided by log of 1.0025
and when i just write log like this it
implicitly means log base 10 and so
let's get our calculator out
and we have and remember n is going to
be in months
so we have
the logarithm of 1.5
divided by the logarithm
the logarithm of 1.0025
gets us
gets us 162.38
months so let me write that down
so that is
162 point i'll just write four
months
and the question that they asked us i
think was to the nearest year to the
nearest whole year how long will it take
well if this is in months we just divide
by 12 for the years so let's just divide
that number by 12.
it'll take 13 and a half years if we
round it to the nearest year which
they're asking us to do if we go to the
tenths place we have a 5 that's
obviously greater than or equal to five
so we round up so we'll round this up to
14 years so this will take approximately
this will take approximately 14 years
14 years at that interest rate to grow
to fifteen hundred dollars